♪
PETE: TEACHERS UNIONS, THE
DEMOCRATS' BIGGEST SUPERPAC,
SPENDING BIG ON DEMOCRATS WITH
JUST NINE DAYS UNTIL THE
MIDTERM.
THE GROUPS LIKE THE NF -- AFT
POURING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS INTO
POLITICAL CAMPAIGNS WITH NEARLY
ALL OF IT, OF COURSE, GOING TO
LEFT-WING CANDIDATES.
HERE TO REACT IS TURNING POINT
USA FOUNDER CHARLIE KIRK.
CHARLIE, YOU TRAVEL THE COUNTRY,
YOU TALK TO PARENTS, STUDENTS.
IS WHAT THE N EVERYTHING A AND
AFT, WHAT THE TEACHERS UNIONS,
WHAT THEY'RE SELLING IN THESE
ADS, IS ANYONE BUYING IT AFTER
WHAT THEY PULLED DURING COVID?
>> NO, BUT THE ENORMITY AND
VOLUME OF RESOURCES IS QUITE
REMARKABLE.
THE NEA AND THE AFT, THEY ARE SO
WORRIED THAT THERE'S A PARENTS'
A PARTY THAT IS GROWING ACROSS
AMERICA THAT IS BIPARTISAN, THAT
IS DIVERSE, THAT IS ACROSS
SOCIOWITH ECONOMIC LINES.
IT IS PARENTS THAT ARE STARTING
TO SHOW UP AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS, AND I I THINK WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO SEE WITH THE
MIDTERMS COMING UP IS WE'RE
GOING TO SEE THIS HIDDEN PARENTS
VOTE IS.
IT'S VERY HARD TO SEE IN THE
POLLING, BUT YOU LOOK AT THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS, YOU LOOK AT
THE LOCKDOWNS, THE MASK
MANDATES, THE DECLINE IN MATH
AND READING SCORES, THIS IS
REALLY V TO PINPOINT BECAUSE
IT'S THAT KIND OF HIDDEN
SUBURBAN VOTER.
THEY MIGHT NOT ARE HAVE LIKED
TRUMP, BUT THEY DON'T LIKE AT
ALL WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THEIR
SCHOOLS.
AND IT'S THE DEMOCRATS THAT OWN
ALL OF IT.
I THINK YOU'RE GOING TO SEE IT
IN THE MINNESOTA, MICHIGAN AND
WISCONSIN GOVERNORS' RACES IN
PARTICULAR, STATE-BASED
GOVERNMENTS THAT WERE OVERLY
DRACONIAN, AND THE NEA AND A
FINISHING T ARE SO WORRIED THAT
IT'S SWEEPING THE COUNTRY WITH
FEWTOWN MOMENTUM.
NEWFOUND MOMENTUM.
PETE: I LIKE THAT.
IF RACES IN ARIZONA, MINNESOTA
AND MICHIGAN ARE TOP -- I KNOW,
KARI LAKE WE'LL HAVE ON THE
PROGRAM IN JUST ABOUT 30
MINUTES.
BUT, CHARLIE, ANOTHER TOPIC,
YOU'VE GOT A NEW DOCUMENTARY OUT
CALLED BORDER BAT.
TAKE A WATCH.
>> THIS ISN'T A WAR THAT ANYBODY
WANTS TO TALK ABOUT.
BUT WE ARE AT WAR.
♪
>> DESCRIBE THE CARTEL?
PURE EVIL.
PETE: CHARLIE, TELL US ABOUT IT.
>> YEAH.
FROM THE EDUCATION CARTEL THAT
WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT TO
THE DRUG CARTEL.
WE'VE BEEN SPENDING ABOUT NINE
MONTHS ON THIS.
WE'RE A BORDER STATE HERE IN
ARIZONA, AND WE MAKE THE
ARGUMENT THAT ACTUALLY EVERY
SINGLE TATE IS A BORDER STATE.
IT'S A PROJECT TO EDUCATE
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ABOUT
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HELPING.
CHECK IT OUT AT SALEM NOW.COM,
AND WE EMBEDDED WITH BORDER
CONTROL, WITH I.C.E., WITH THE
GREAT SHERIFF, MARK LAMB, TO
EDUCATE PEOPLE ON THE DRUGS, THE
CRIME, THE CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING BECAUSE OF
A POROUS SOUTHERN BORDER.
I THINK THIS IS A MAJOR ISSUE
THAT PEOPLE DON'T QUITE
UNDERSTAND, OH, YEAH, PEOPLE ARE
ARE CROSSING.
NO, THIS IS AN ISSUE OF
SOVEREIGNTY, OUR KIDS, AND RIGHT
NOW ACROSS AMERICA THERE ARE
KIDS TAKING FENTANYL PILLS THAT
WALTZED ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER BECAUSE OUR GOVERNMENT
ALLOWED IT TO HAPPEN.
SALEM NOW.COM IF PEOPLE WANT TO
CHECK IT OUT.
I THINK EVERY AMERICAN NEEDS TO
PROPERLY EDUCATE THEMSELVES ON
THE BORDER SO WE CAN WITH SO
THIS PROBLEM ONCE AND -- SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM ONCE AND FOR ALL.
PETE: YOU'VE GOT SOVEREIGNTY
VERSUS ANARCHY, THAT'S
BASICALLY, IF YOU WANT TO BREAK
IT DOWN, IT'S A SANITY ELECTION.
>> CHOOSE WISELY.
PETE: YES.
AS IF YO